okay underneath that diagram you've got
a whole bunch of questions okay
these questions and they're kind of
phrased in a weird way not in the way
that you would normally see questions
like this so I'm going to start you off
and then I think you'll be able to get
all the way through to the end of this
okay so this stuff here just have a look
at it here I'm sorry it's just the first
loan all of this stuff here I hope I've
represented that on the diagram that you
have up above so I've got a whole bunch
of right angles there and I've got that
length o P it's that hypotenuse Q see
that hypotenuse up there in that big
right angle triangle okay so how are we
going to get to a result for sine of a
plus B alpha plus beta using using this
weird contraption okay well what we're
going to do is we're going to find any
angles that we can see in this diagram
in terms of alpha and beta which are
down here every angle in this diagram
you can find in terms of those okay and
then any distances so for example the
first one we're going to work out is PQ
any distances on the diagram can be
stated in terms of sine or cos or tan of
those angles okay in this case you'll
see it's only sailing cos that we need
okay so the first one I'm interested in
is PQ this guy here can you see it maybe
you want to mark it out in in some color
or something like that
now how do I find out what that length
is in terms of the alphas and the beta's
they're in this diagram okay well I hope
you can see that PQ this length
it exists in I need a thicker pencil in
this triangle here do you see that do
you see that PQ is one of these short
sides in this right angled triangle here
so if it's a right angle triangle that
means you can use right angled triangle
trig yeah really really simple stuff
just ratios yeah so what is the one and
only angle whose size you know in this
triangle a lot of trick question have a
look down there in the bottom left-hand
corner it's beta right that's better
so hmm there's beater over here I know
that this hypotenuse is one what is this
side PQ in relation to
this is this is the opposite side right
so it's off all the way on the opposite
side so this the trig trap and the trig
ratio I would use is sown right
sine of beta you can use any spy on the
paper you like I'll put this in your
book if you want Santa Fe do is just
going to be opposite on hypotenuse yeah
which is what in this case it's what's
the name of this thing this is PQ PQ is
the opposite side and what's the
hypotenuse it's just one so right there
you can see what PQ is equal to its sine
beta like so I'll do one more for you
just because the next one is so related
distance OQ is the next thing we want to
have a look at so that's let's do it in
red that's this guy here it's in the
same triangle but it's got a different
relationship so beta so what will I use
it's adjacent right some your knees
cause someone use this guy yeah so this
is going to be adjacent on hypotenuse so
you can see what Oh Q is equal to the
divided by one just cancels out so
that's cos beta so we're not used to I
mean we're used to saying oh this length
is 15 or 11 or some number right but I'm
saying as a trig ratio okay now those of
you seen this before should be able to
zip right through this we're trying to
find sine of alpha plus beta I'll let
you work out where that is by the time
you get to the bottom I think you'll be
fine so give that a go give it a run
through and then let's see how we can
use these for finding all of the other
tree expansions okay I'll give you that
three minutes I can get there so we're
going to take these results and you can
see what we come to right down the
bottom here this project is doing
something funny anyway there's my result
down the bottom yeah so this is ringing
bells
I hope serene valves my getting nods yes
nice low nods okay good so let's
summarize this right because we can use
this to get every other one of the tree
expansions which you may have heard of
his company agels but I like to think of
them this way we've got this result sine
a cos B plus cos a sine B which I've
just used to replace
and bees with alphas and beaters just
because I was gonna have too many
coordinates flying around if I use the
same letters say I hope you're happy
with that now when we go to replace it a
plus B with a minus B what difference
does it make it flips a sign around now
I wonder if you remember why if you
think about this guy I'm gonna write it
in a slightly different way as a plus
negative B is that okay a minus B is the
same as a plus negative B well every
time you see B you can replace that with
negative B but look what happens if I do
cause of negative B what kind of a
function is cause what kind of symmetry
does it have it has um it has even
symmetry right which means if you put in
like cos 90 it with sorry cos 90 it
would be the same as cos negative 90
right they're exactly the same
so therefore cos of being and cos of
negative B are also the same so I could
write them as the same thing right
that's why there's no change in the
middle but over here when you put the
negative B into here right what happens
is sine sine has its own kind of
symmetry what symmetry is that it's odd
right so if you put negative being here
has the same effect as flipping out that
sign in the front so that's where this
expansion comes from yeah when you go
over to cause what's different it's look
so very similar but not yeah instead of
a mismatching your functions are PR you
match them so you start with cause
because this is cause after all
and you mismatch your sign instead
you're plus minus your operation I
should say and then you can hopefully
remember all of these which is what we
use to great effect in auxilary angle
which has been a while there which is
what I wanted to come back to this right
who remembers these OOP he's a pretty
tough let's see Shalini you're it
showing out
very good very nice and by the way I'll
say this like I said before these are on
the reference sheet but I don't want you
to have to rely on the reference sheet
for these it's so much better faster and
less error-prone if you actually know
what these are and I think they're well
within your grasp what difference does
it make when I go to - yeah it's the
same deal because tan has the same kind
of symmetry as sine right so it's the
same switching your sides so there's a
minus on the top and a plus on the
bottom okay with that